after 13 weeks of the regular season
Peter you have the honors what would you
like to complain about
I would like to complain about how we
take Jerry Jones words as gospel you
know we hang on his words we publish his
words we listen to his words and the
fact is they should just most of them
should just disappear into the ether
because they're like Jason Garrett's
gonna coach next year in the NFL what
does that mean is he gonna be a head
coach is he gonna be an assistant coach
is he gonna be the Dallas coach is he
gonna be the Jacksonville coach is he
gonna be a quality-control coach is he
gonna coach his kids high school team
and I'm kidding I don't think he has a
kids high school team but you know we
take his words like they're very
meaningful they are not very meaningful
very often yeah I mean I hear you well
when you had when you talk publicly
twice a week you're right there's only
so many things you could say meaningful
and you know I think the big thing he
does there's like a lot more than twice
it doesn't seem a lot more than that
you're right he makes himself available
to the people of Texas and I think
that's what he's really trying to do and
I know the you know having played down
there I think there's probably great
appreciation from the fan base to feel
like they're getting inside knowledge
from a guy like that but you're right
for us guys in the football world it
gets a little old at times and he
doesn't just speak twice a week he
speaks twice a week on radio than that
he holds a press conference with any
reporter who happens to be in the
vicinity and they crowd around I mean
he'll talk endlessly Shereen Williams at
home games she is there and she types
that up and it takes a half hour to read
the damn transcript of everything he's
had to say consider what Troy Aikman
said recently on Katie CK am and this is
a great example you've got a head coach
who comes down and says we're going to
evaluate the kicker and then the front
office says right after that probably in
a press conference right outside the
locker room they aren't evaluating the
kicker all those things have an impact
and it slowly trickles down and Peter
you may be onto something here because
it isn't just words into the ether it is
something that impacts
undermines the message that Jason
Garrett's trying to send and I think all
that talk last week complaining about
Jason Garrett was aimed at getting the
lawn mowers started so they'd went on
Thanksgiving and it backfired it blew up
and the team was not as as unified as
maybe Jones hoped they would be when he
decided to push Jason Garrett back
against the wall cuz he thought hey
every other time Jason Garrett's backs
against the wall it's worked this time
it didn't so it you know it blows hot
and cold he's good cop and bad cop all
in the same guy it just depends on what
day it is or what minute it is and again
I still love listening to him because he
gives us things to talk about but I
don't know how much it helps this team
yeah well that's where you got to defend
that's where you defend Jason Garrett
sometimes and you go hey it's not easy
to be the head coach of the Dallas
Cowboys I mean it's not that's just the
simple fact of the matter because of all
the reasons you guys just stated all
right my grievance is this there's
nothing too serious all right
but this is driving me crazy it's been
driving me crazy for about six or seven
weeks all right I am sick of us having
to go to commercial break during a
football game because a guy is injured
on the field and then we come back after
three minutes right and oh it was his
hand that was hurt he hit his hand and
it hurt a little bit but he had a lay on
the ground and we had to go to
commercial break and then he's in on the
very next play that is driving me crazy
I want like if you if we have to go to
commercial break and you're out of the
game there should be like it you can't
come back in for ten more plays I am so
sick of that right now as players there
you know I can siddur myself old school
to a degree like if you can walk off the
field get the hell off the field okay
I'm just and the games are long enough
as is I don't want to be like oh okay
we've gotten to a three-minute
commercial break hey the guy that we
went to the break for you know he he he
he moved his arm around and he's good
and he's back in again next play and
that's it just drives me crazy I'm sorry
I don't I don't know what more to say
about it
so between mildly wounded hand and
ruptured spleen at the other extreme
where's the line
a whole bunch it happened in the second
series of the game I kept going damn I
don't feel right but I'm gonna walk off
the field alright sorry Mike I've got
one more grievance can I air it right
now or do you want your ears let me
remind I'm here am i er go ahead you
wear yours all right let me are mine and
and I don't think it's ever gonna change
but there is something fundamentally
unfair about what's gonna happen at the
end of this season and Peter you
mentioned it earlier when the Dallas
Cowboys at 8 and 8 or 9 and 7 host the
San Francisco 49ers or the Seattle
Seahawks at 12 and 4 or 13 and 3 now
Seattle can't complain about it because
they were the 7 & 9 team nine years ago
that hosted the 11 and 5 Saints and won
the game in large part because they
hosted it people said after the game
well it shows the Seahawks were the
better team no it does it because if
they had played the game in New Orleans
New Orleans would have won the game
that's one of those cases where
home-field advantage determines the
outcome of a game and even more
importantly Peter and Chris the idea
that the Cowboys could have the division
locked up by week 16 rest their starters
week 17 and then host a team that was in
a bloodbath
with its NFC West rival and may have
nothing left after only one week and the
Cowboys starters arrested because they
didn't have to play against Washington
week 17 giving them even more of an
advantage for this unfair and they're
not going to change it they love the
fact that if you win your division
you're in the playoffs and you get a
home game I don't think it's ever gonna
change I don't like it because once
every three or four years something
grossly unfair like this happens and
it's gonna happen this year you know the
NFL always talks about you know hey it's
a level playing field we want to create
equal opportunity for everybody I mean
they do with the draft they do with with
all kinds of things the waiver wire this
is patently pathetically ridiculously
unfair the San Francisco 49ers there's a
decent chance that they're going 13 and
3 they'll be the five seed and they're
going to go on the road in the first
round of the playoffs and play a team
that won eight or nine games and listen
this is not even an argument that it's
ridiculous it's not even an argument
that it's patently unfair no one has
come up with anything to me to say
anything about the fairness of this
other than well those are the rules we
automatically give division winners a
home playoff game why tell me why tell
me why you know you automatically put
the put the extra point you know at the
two yardline forever and now you moved
it back to the 15 so it's actually a
play that means something this is
exactly the same thing there's something
wrong with the game it's the simplest
fix in the world vote on it fix it yeah
I listen I I'm with you I mean again I
don't know I like the way it is I maybe
I'm one of those guys I don't want to
reseat it I do think there's you know
one of those guys yeah I know I'm one of
those guys I am I guess I'm a
traditional is that way and also you
know again sometimes I also look at it
like alright you could have a team
that's let's say eleven and five or
something like that in a given year in a
certain division right where the
divisions not very good and you got a
conference you know a division champion
who's let's say nine and seven and eight
and eight but there's like it was a
tough division altogether and it's just
it's not I don't know I don't know if
it's always apples to apples I guess is
what I'm saying
you could be playing in a division
that's hot more highly competitive than
another division that's not that doesn't
hold true to this year I mean to what no
it definitely does no it does not
definitely does rest is I get better
across the board than just give an
example of another given year that it
could be that way so that's all I'm
saying but I want to hear your last
grievance either way Peter because I
know you had one more all right here's
my last grievance the Denver Broncos
beat the Los Angeles chargers on Sunday
not because at the end of the game they
were the better team right it's because
at the end of the game they gained the
system they got a 37 yard pass
interference penalty not because we
drew Locke went out and threw a bomb you
know with eight seconds to go or
Everidge time there was not because when
he threw a bomb he thought he was going
to complete it it's because the Denver
Broncos thought there was a 15 or 20%
chance that they would get past
interference and that's exactly what
happened
they got a free pass interference call a
borderline pass interference call
although yeah I agreed that it was pass
interference but it should have been a
15-yard penalty not a 37 yard penalty
and that field goal should have been a
75 yard field goal not a 53-yard field
goal I hate the spot foul on defensive
pass interference and I will argue to my
death that it is the dumbest rule in NFL
history I could think of Dumber rules
but I agree with you especially I mean
when you're talking about us now
the fumble out of the end zone the other
team getting the ball at the 20 the
important is this rule though well not
as important this rule happens all the
time both of those rules obits five
times a year I love both of those rules
Laurie oh you're wrong sorry
even you lose the ball than somebody
else's territory it becomes their ball
just like anything else all right and
you're wrong too Peter
I mean what no I'm not we'll see
penalties all game long anytime a guy's
beat this ridiculous statement why you
played college football at the highest
level right and it killed us a time I
had Roy Williams who was a top 10 pick
and when he became people who often did
people tackle him in the open field
every week no but I was a handful times
a handful of you through the year good
and so here's what you do in the NFL
right here's exactly what you do in the
NFL okay you take away you take away the
spot foul element okay you make it a
15-yard play but if there is a blatant
tackle of a pass receiver running
downfield that is a spot foul but but
I'm telling you David Shaw the Stanford
coach told me this a couple of years ago
you hardly ever see it it hardly ever
happens so let's put in an insurance
policy for when it does happen if Casey
Hayward on that play tackled Courtland
Sutton okay it's a spot foul 37 yard
penalty he didn't he bumped into him and
there's a good chance he bumped into him
accidentally not on purpose so yeah
there's no way that that should be a 37
yard penalty
well I ridiculous there's a lot of
things that it was a bad call first
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports